a seven-ship british fleet cuts into the
pirate bay of nassau with imperial pomp
and fixes its anchors into the seabed
for the night
captain woods rogers has triumphantly
arrived to impose the will of his royal
majesty king george of great britain and
ireland
in the morning he will tame this
wretched pirate haven and finally
cleanse it from scum and villainy
night falls and the crescent moon lights
up the deep ocean
there is the gentle crack of bending
wood
as two ships push off from the island
the nearest ship sails directly towards
rogers
it heaves forward then bursts into
flames
the crew escapes on queue as shrapnel
blisters and spits in orange streaks
over black waters
crackling inferno spreads to one british
ship and the others scatter in the
frenzy
the fire ship's crew rode to the second
vessel and joined their tenacious leader
the ruthless pirate who deigns to defy
the king
charles
vane
woods rogers watches him escape into the
smoldering tropical night
[Music]
vayne understood perfectly well why
rogers and the civilized world wanted to
see him hang
theft torture and murder were sins to
which he shamelessly admitted
he reserved less sympathy for the
schools of pirates who had betrayed him
indeed many men he knew had stayed
behind to welcome woods rogers into
nassau they had elected to accept this
so-called king's pardon
but vain had taken his chances he was no
coward and wouldn't give up his paradise
that easily
nassau which constituted the island of
new providence in the caribbean had
fallen out of british hands some years
ago
its winding farmlands and cobwebbed
cannons duly became the property of
charles vane blackbeard benjamin
hornegold and thousands of other pirates
together they had fashioned the island
into a republic of pirates from which to
plunder this corner of the atlantic
a liminal anarchy between english
spanish and french dominions
but so great were those spoils that
those royal dynasties of europe fretted
upon their thrones and decried the
unkempt outlaws who so want and they
emptied their treasures
and so woods rogers had been tasked with
their extermination
despite charles vanes fiery attack
rogers successfully made landfall the
next morning he pardoned every pacified
pirate ashore and raised the union jack
atop the dusty fort
the hunt for the others who roamed the
seas was already underway
those who persisted in their thievery
were brought back to nassau and walked
to the gallows in front of their former
shipmates who had accepted the pardon
woods rogers sat as governor of nassau
an age of order was upon them
[Music]
this seemed a momentous occasion if
charles vane blackbeard and the other
stragglers dared to resist they would
have a front row seat to the end of
their way of life
and indeed this appeared to be the death
of a people who had long thrived like
mold on the dark underbellies of
celebrated empires a people whose
blood-stained legacy of freedom butchery
and rebellion had begun eons before
a proud history of piracy
millennia long preceded these men
from empire toppling flotillas to
singular scoundrels and back again
this
is their story
this
is the story
of the pirates
of the west
pirates didn't really have schools their
training was mainly from their previous
lives as legitimate sea folk taking
their previous sailing skills and using
them to their advantage these days it's
harder to do this so directly so
services like skillshare are hugely
helpful to train up for a new career or
progress in your current one and it's
not just great for advancing your career
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inventive
and creative classes to choose from one
great class i always come back to on
skillshare is creative video
storytelling and editing making the most
of stock footage we use stock footage
mixed in with images here at voices of
the past and this class has been great
for exploring new ways to create videos
and tell stories it's just one of the
many fantastic classes they have on
documentaries and filmmaking and it's
just as useful as my previous
recommendation creating a modern
cinematic documentary film with soul a
staff pick and a gem on the platform so
skillshare are the perfect option to
make the rest of 2022 a productive and
creative journey the first thousand
people to use the link in my description
will get a one month free trial of
skillshare so you can start exploring
your creativity today thanks to
skillshare for supporting history
content on youtube
[Music]
all at once the lands were removed and
scattered in the fray no land could
stand before their arms
they were coming forward towards egypt
while the flame was prepared before them
life proceeded in egypt as it had for
thousands of years
high priests venerated monuments to the
pharaohs of old while preaching cryptic
wisdom of the gods
camels carried travellers across searing
dunes and crocodiles cooled their scales
in the flowing nile along its banks
common folk tended to the fertile earth
by day and spent cold nights cloistered
in their mud-brick dwellings
and above it all on an ornate throne
amidst monuments to his own glory
sat a king
beset
by tortured thoughts
the 42 year old pharaoh ramses iii was
the living incarnation of the avian god
horus said to will the very movement of
the sun and moon but ramses had been
fated to rule over a bloody age
for it was 1175 bc
and the very idea of civilization itself
was in danger
an existential threat stalked the
mediterranean powerful confederations of
seafaring tribes whose ranks were filled
with masterful sailors savvy traders and
tenacious pirates
coastal cities were engulfed in flames
they desolated its people and its land
was like that which has never come into
being
ramses watched as the pirates ushered in
the bronze age collapse seeing his
rivals fall to ruin syria the levant
cyprus and greece would crumble the
final hour of egypt must have been close
as these proto-pirates charted course to
the nile the pharaoh called forth men
from all corners of the kingdom and
furnished them with shining lances bows
and chariots
the enemy flooded into the delta their
light vessels carried raiders clad in
all manner of armor but undivided in
their determination to topple the old
world
a hail of arrows rained down the
egyptians charged with lances squeezed
their opponents at a choke point and ran
their ships aground
then they ripped the pirates onto the
sand and hacked them to death
they were dragged in enclosed and
prostrated on the beach killed and made
into heaps from tail to head
finally a grisly red tide beat against
the sides of overturned ships
ramses had prevailed and the onslaught
of the piratical sea peoples
was halted
and so it was this apocalyptic battle of
the delta that was memorialized on the
outer walls of midinet habu
it may be the earliest depiction of a
pirate attack in existence
it is likely that for as long as people
have elected to transport things of
value over the ocean there have existed
people who endeavored to steal those
things
but if piracy comprises robbery and
violence on the high seas and coastal
areas the sea peoples showed that its
practitioners need not be mere
ship-borne bandits on the contrary the
sea peoples traded migrated and
prudently navigated political
allegiances indeed the pre-classical
ancient greeks understood that piracy
had once been considered an entirely
legitimate source of financial
sustenance the jagged edges of the
mediterranean were unsuitable for
large-scale agriculture but passing
trade ships hugged the coastlines like
tempting sirens they beckoned sailors
and fishermen towards a treacherous life
of piracy
barbarians were tempted to turn pirates
under the conduct of their most powerful
men the motives being to serve their own
greed and to support the needy they
would fall upon a town unprotected by
walls and consisting of a mere
collection of villages and would plunder
it
indeed this came to be the main source
of their livelihood no disgrace being
yet attached to such an achievement
but even some
glory while small bands of piratical
opportunists proved an inevitable
reality to the ancient world many of the
most fervent practitioners of piracy
were more legitimate states or
confederacies entire people like the
illyrians and phoenicians participated
in large-scale trading and cultural
exchange in addition to fairly
indiscriminate piracy
but pirates nevertheless thrived on
instability in a pattern that would
characterize piracy for millennia to
come places that had fallen into ruin
due to war or neglect became the most
attractive pirate tents the cracked
vestiges of the minoan civilization on
crete and islands scarred by
peloponnesian conflict became bases for
pirates to organize raids on ships and
coasts
ancient pirates conquered ill-guarded
land pillaged ships and coastlines and
conducted slave raids in a manner not
dissimilar from contemporary empires
defining which kinds of ship worn
robbery fell outside the law would
continue to be a matter of perspective
and convenience
but the winds of empire threatened
piracy as alexander toppled cities and
the star of rome enveloped greece
pirate hegemony
waned
the northern greek italian league which
had practiced large-scale piracy against
its enemies was defeated by the roman
republic in 192 bc
but the romans had simply pushed the
issue beyond their gaze
the itolian pirates fled and set up
operations in the nook of asia minor
based in the dilapidated towns of
cilicia the most fearsome pirate
community the ancient world had ever
seen now swarmed the mediterranean
in their voracious slave raiding these
silicean pirates made friends
in powerful places
the hostage refused to stay quiet
in truth his captors found him amusing
drunken cackling of sunburned pirates
echoed along the coast as they watched
him perform poems and speeches with
boyish pluck the warm turquoise borders
of the eastern mediterranean his
tranquil prison the confused cilicians
listened intently to the brash young
roman their hostage had suggested they
raised the ransom for his freedom to
more accurately reflect his status and
the cilicians had complied
his countrymen may have controlled the
western mediterranean but the eastern
half remained pirate territory the
cilicians attacked with little regard
for the allegiances of their victims the
powerful landowners and senators of rome
nevertheless tolerated them as the
profitability of their sweeping
plantations depended on a stable
relationship with the pirates for
peacetime in the republic
made for bad business without conquered
peoples to be sold in roman markets
roman landowners turned to the silicean
pirates who eagerly sold them people
they had captured in slave rates
if pirates were to roam the seas empires
would continue to find ways to use their
presence to their advantage
but siliceon looting of roman shipping
also created fervent enemies in rome
and so rome began to enact anti-piracy
laws
the derision with which the roman
hostage treated his captors may have
reflected this change in attitudes when
he wished to sleep the roman would
interrupt the late night revelry of the
pirates and tell them to stop talking in
passing he muttered teasing threats to
have his captors executed
after a month the ransom came and the
young captive named julius caesar sailed
off
[Music]
the pirates decided to linger on the
coast a little while longer bobbing at
anchor and basking in their earnings
but their celebrations were soon cut
short
a fleet appeared on the horizon
caesar had returned
he had the pirates thrown in prison and
reclaimed the ransom money
he went to pergamon took the pirates out
of prison and crucified the lot of them
just as he had often told them he would
do when he was on the island
and they imagined that he was joking
but silesian pirates continued to
undermine the stability of the roman
republic indeed when spartacus launched
a slave revolt two years later in 73 bc
the siliceans supported his efforts
though when spartacus met with the
pirates and paid them to transport two
thousand of his rebels to sicily the
civilians took the gifts and sailed off
without them
they then burned the roman port of
austria and kidnapped two roman senators
now common romans felt the material
shock on grain supplies in the economy
they looked to the rising general pompey
to confront the issue and he in turn
gathered support for a costly mission
the complete annihilation of the
cilician pirates
the senate passed the gabanen law
the law gave him dominion over the sea
this side of the pillars of hercules
over all the mainland to the distance of
400 furlongs from the sea
these limits included almost all places
in the roman world and the greatest
nations and most powerful kings were
comprised within them
with over a hundred thousand troops at
his disposal pompey sent forth his army
to hound the pirates at every corner
they blockaded and demolished pirate
lairs and drove many of the stragglers
back to cilicia roman ships followed
them and formed impenetrable rows of
blockades forcing the pirates onto land
from there the roman troops slaughtered
the pirates with mechanical efficiency
upon their surrender pompey had cilician
leaders killed
the others he showed mercy reflecting
therefore that by nature man neither is
nor becomes a wild or an unsocial
creature but is transformed by the
unnatural practice of vice he determined
to transfer the men from the sea to the
land and let them have a taste of gentle
life by being accustomed to dwell in
cities and to till the ground
pompey had tamed the seas
in all he had raised 120 pirate bases
destroyed 500 ships and killed 10 000
pirates a pax romana washed over the
mediterranean and in the coming
centuries friends of rome were free to
sail without serious danger
piracy it seemed had been defeated once
and for all
so long as the eternal city of rome
stood the western pirate would remain
extinct
a shout echoed through the cold
corridors of a castle pirate brethren
scrambled to their posts and peered
beyond the walls
cutting across soft mounds of snow was a
line of clattering iron and black
crosses the pirates readied their feeble
defenses as the teutonic knights marched
with gleaming swords and crossbows
the soldiers of christ had come to carry
out a royal bounty a quest to slaughter
the doomed pirates in their fortress and
finally end medieval piracy a bloody
error of seabourn banditry inaugurated
centuries earlier
by heathens
the pagans from the northern regions
came with a naval force to britain like
stinging hornets and spread on all sides
like fearful wolves
robbed tore and slaughtered not only
beasts of burden sheep and oxen but even
priests and deacons and companies of
monks and nuns
and they came to the church of
lindisfarne laid everything waste with
grievous plundering trampled the holy
places and polluted steps dug up the
altars and seized all the treasures of
the holy church
they killed some of the brothers took
some away with them in fetters many they
drove out naked and loaded with insults
some they drowned in the sea
through beards doused in frothy mead men
of the north orchestrated the downfall
of far-off kingdoms in their mead halls
they gathered before a crackling hearth
and wooden throne in a quest for untold
riches and immortal glory in valhalla
the fractured nations of northern europe
had left shining treasures and exotic
goods on their shores
exposed and ready to be plundered
viking piracy did not constitute robbery
on the high seas but instead took the
form of lightning coastal raids
shipborne attacks on wherever they saw
wealth earned them precious artifacts
and innumerable slaves
over the centuries disjointed raids on
small villages and monasteries had grown
to fully fledged excursions upon cities
and vast territories
these
vikings or raiders terrorized the
distant corners of europe the audacious
hasting and bjorn ironside ventured as
far as islamic spain sowing chaos on the
sun-kissed guadalcave river in seville
for the stability of the western roman
empire had long since collapsed though
the eastern empire had clung on they
held no real sway in rome's heartland
and soon muslim factions had gained
footholds in north africa iberia and the
middle east
then came the crusades and the eastern
roman empire too fractured into a series
of rump states ceasing to exist
in the ruins of this second empire
pirates returned the very sailors who
had once filled the ranks of the
byzantine navy set up hideouts at its
crumbling corners and began to ambush
merchant ships
but rumblings from the east foretold a
new wave of chaos an unstoppable horde
of step warriors riding west under the
banner of chingus khan
with pirates infesting the coasts and
mongols at the gates a claimant to the
defunct byzantine throne emerged michael
viii retook constantinople and
resurrected an empire which had lain
dormant for six decades but the return
of byzantine authority did not guarantee
stability unable to muster a true
national navy he decided to weaponize
mediterranean pirates for byzantine ends
he called pirate leaders from their
remote hideouts and turned them into his
privateers
sailors who could use their own ships to
plunder under byzantine authority
legitimate piracy was born
this would set a precedent for the
centuries to come
pirates were above all shape-shifters
opportunists disposed to true piracy at
times and the legal protection of
privateering at others
men who had for years ruled as pirates
now justified their pillaging and
violence against italian trade under the
banner of the byzantine empire
for a cash-strapped kingdom seabourn
mercenaries presented a viable
alternative to a legitimate navy
and northern europe would soon realize
this as well
the deposed swedish king albert sat in a
dungeon in desperate need of aid
scattered beyond his city of stockholm
were forested specks of land sat in dark
and briny waters glacial currents
shimmered with herring and bent under
the strain of hostile ships that
infested the harbour
this was a suffocating blockade a gift
from the new swedish monarch margaret of
denmark
at roughly 40 years of age the shrewd
queen margaret claimed rulership over
all scandinavia the dark-haired queen
known to be beautiful and intimidating
in equal measure was hell-bent on
uniting the region at all costs
thus as stockholm remained loyal to king
albert margaret decided to starve the
city
no ordinary sailor could penetrate the
swarm the allies of king albert turned
instead
to professionals
handsomely paid german mercenaries were
sent to slip through the blockade and
run supplies into stockholm
wreaking havoc on the merchant vessels
of margaret and her allies together they
formed a guild called the victor
brothers
now in need of a safe base of operations
the victoria brothers took the town of
visby on the island of gotland one of
margaret's swedish territories and in
1394 the unabashed pirates became the de
facto rulers of gotland
the seas were in chaos
the viktual brothers assailed so many
passing ships the trade became all but
impossible
economies floundered the fishing
industry was halted and food supplies
dwindled in exasperated meetings
margaret called for aid
it was an old order of knights that took
up the queen's quest based in prussia
the crusaders of the teutonic order came
forward with troops prepared with
broadswords and exquisite shining armor
they boasted menacing visored helmets
and shields bearing black crosses
the knights desired to control gotland
queen margaret promised to grant their
wish if they could clear the island of
the pirates
and so in the winter of 1397
the victual brothers docked their ships
for the last time
almost all came ashore to weather the
scandinavian cold on gotland
the knights and their prussian troops
sailed out in secret to meet them
eighty-four ships and four thousand men
were to attack under the leadership of
grand master conrad von youngengan
they clamored ashore and met the pirates
in the snow as negotiations for peace
took place the pirates and their
prussian army marched to every corner of
the island they found the pirates tucked
away in castles and forts they laid
siege to their defenses and hacked to
death and filled with arrows the victor
brothers they found the knights finally
demolished the city of visby and
conquered the island they afforded the
pirates three days to leave those who
lingered were captured and killed
leaders like klaus sturtebecker
continued pirating for years but even he
was caught brought in and executed with
his crew
if european waters had truly fallen into
the hands of powerful kings and queens
like margaret then piracy would need to
move beyond their gaze
perhaps there was money to be made
further afield
and indeed in a century's time europeans
would begin making dangerous forays into
an uncharted ocean for explorers and
conquistadors had stumbled upon a new
hemisphere of jungles tropical islands
and vast civilizations brimming with
wealth
pirates and politically useful
privateers would soon take notice
eyes of a scowling aztec god set into
priceless gold
chests of clattering gems lumps of
silver and sacred headdresses
alive draguar bearing its teeth with
every sway of the ship
and a spanish sailor trying his best
to not make eye contact
stolen souvenirs from the new world
courtesy of hernan cortes cortes and his
ironclad conquistadors had waded through
the mexican jungle orchestrating a large
indigenous resistance against aztec rule
they had then used the chaos to wrest
control of the region and bleed the
crumbling empire of montezuma of its
abundant wealth
now the trio of spanish ships creaked
home heavy with treasure the sailors
were to guard the secret cargo at all
costs
their gaze swept over the horizon as
they awaited a pair of armed vessels to
escort them on the last leg of their
journey
but instead
one by one strange ships rose above the
curve of the atlantic
five mysterious boats swarmed after the
spanish trio the treasure-laden ships
groaned and clanked as the spaniards
wheeled hard in the opposite direction
the attackers dogged them for hours
until at last they apprehended two of
them
with sharpened blades and feathered
flamboyance captain jean fleury and his
french crew demanded they surrender lest
they come aboard by force and duly
butcher every spaniard they saw
the exhausted spaniards surrendered
without fanfare and the frenchman came
aboard to haul away the treasure chest
by chest
in the eyes of france jean fleury was
not a criminal but a hero for he
possessed a document called the letter
of mark these were licenses issued
during war which offered sailors the
legal permission of their home country
to hunt attack and capture non-combat
vessels of rival nations men who might
have otherwise been hunted as pirates
could function as private agents of the
state or
privateers allowed to declare and keep
most of the loot they plundered
privateers like fleury were the product
of a changing europe whose fractured
kingdoms had begun to crystallize into
potent empires the kingdom of france had
risen in competition with the other
established monarchies of spain portugal
and the holy roman empire locked in the
east by the muslim ottoman empire these
warring western european dynasties began
seeking alternative routes to the
lucrative east indies
columbus had made landfall on american
soil in 1492
and now conquistadors sailed about the
americas in search of glory land and
treasure but if spain had truly landed
in a new world her burgeoning empire
would become the natural target of her
rivals
even after his capture as jean fleury
swung from the gallows the frenchman had
set something in motion his privateering
had revealed to the world what riches
the spanish had uncovered in their
grisly new world conquests and placed a
target on their treasure-laden vessels
and in 1536 the french attacked havana
and other spanish new world ports the
following year french privateers cut in
half the spanish income from the new
world
spain recognized its treasure ships were
in dire need of protection so the crown
developed the floater system no longer
would treasure ships travel exposed
across the atlantic well armed convoys
were rallied to escort them seaside
frauds with armored soldiers and cannons
would also be raised around key ports
and in the wake of peace between spain
and france in 1559 french letters of
mark dried up and legitimate french
privateers disappeared from the spanish
maine
but that
was far
from the end for across the channel
elizabeth the first took up their mantle
the english queen a staunch protestant
viewed spain as a bitter political and
religious rival
armed with her own letters of mark
she
let loose
her sea dogs
[Music]
camped at the edge of a chirping jungle
stood a goateed adventurer an intrepid
englishman with vengeance in his heart
for this secret mission francis drake
had assembled a band of loot hungry
individuals english privateers like
himself the french buccaneer le tetsu
and a network of savvy runaway slaves
drake could track the spanish treasure
shipments all the way here to the
isthmus of panama in the morning new
loads would secretly cart south american
treasures to the city of nombre de dios
before they were shipped back to spain
the son of a farmer drake desired most
of all riches and glory the spanish had
thwarted his commercial endeavors in the
new world
they were a natural target bells rang
out the caravan approached 200 mules
labored forward laden with 30 tons of
new world treasure dozens of spanish
soldiers marched alongside them
drake
met them head-on
in the end these soldiers thought it the
best way to leave their mules with us
and to seek for more help abroad in
which meantime we took some pain to ease
some of the mules which were heaviest
loading of their carriage and because we
ourselves were somewhat weary we were
contented with a few bars and coits of
gold as we could well carry burying
about 15 tons of silver spanish
reinforcements would arrive any minute
with glowing gold in their arms drake
and his men marched for miles under damp
vines and dangling vipers
finally they neared the edge of the
mountainous jungle as they stumbled onto
the beach where they left their ships
they found that they had disappeared
spanish vessels looming along the
coastline in their place the pirates
could see their capture and death were
imminent
drake acted quickly he ordered his men
to bury their gold and make a raft from
the trees they drifted 10 miles down the
coast until they reached his flagship
and safety
drake later returned to recover the gold
took her captain's portion for himself
and divided the rest amongst the french
and english
this first foray into the world of
privateering would enable an illustrious
career
drake returned to england a celebrity of
sorts and forged a close relationship
with the queen who affectionately
referred to him as my pirate
sending him on various unofficial
missions to plunder the ships of her
spanish rivals in his elegant vessel the
golden hind drake circumnavigated the
planet harassing and plundering spanish
ports and ships along the way driven
more by opportunity than any lofty
ideals drake could just as easily
plunder the spanish mane shoulder to
shoulder with runaway slaves as he could
sell captured africans into slavery and
after warding off the spanish armada's
attack on england drake became something
of a national hero of course
self-interest could underlie his actions
at any time in 1588 when tasked with
shadowing the invading spanish armada he
defied orders and instead hunted after a
treasure-filled ship since the crown
took its cut of all privateer plunder
drake hid half of this stolen gold
before returning to london and bought
himself a mansion
this was the unique duality of
privateering where greed and
self-interest could shakely co-exist
with national service french english and
dutch privateers readily hoisted their
sails for the promise of untold wealth
and were hailed as rugged heroes in
their home countries
an account of drake's exploits co-signed
by the man himself was titled sir
francis drake revived calling upon this
dull or effeminate age to follow his
noble steps for gold and silver
though peace between spain and england
would come and the era of unchecked
privateering would pass that same
century saw the terrifying rise of a
pirate power further east
perched on the northern edge of africa
muslim pirates attacked the very heart
of the christian empires that laid claim
to the americas conquistadors left
american soil and returned to the
mediterranean in anxious haste
a storm
was brewing
it was said that until the late 19th
century a mountain of skulls stood on
the tunisian island of jeriba
passes by would gaze upon a yellowed
tower of human bone
sunken faces with mouths a gape
the heads had been harvested from
spanish sailors three centuries prior
they were the victims of a man
called dragoot
[Music]
the newest slave brought with him
notoriety rumors about him had spread
throughout the stinking italian ship
tales of his escapades when black stacks
of smoke had bloomed along the italian
coast and his pointed ships carried away
goods and people
they said he was a great barbary pirate
by the name of dragoot
whispers spread that he'd even trained
under the famed corsair high readin
barbarossa together felling italian
fortresses and capturing precious
merchant ships from distant infidels
these rumors were true
like all barbary corsairs dragoot had
acted as a pirate or privateer ravaging
christian coastlines and exchanging a
cut of the loot for safety and status in
the islamic coastal polities of north
africa or the so-called barbary states
the region offered little in the way of
natural resources so rulers had
developed states reliant on mass piracy
though functionally quite independent
the barbary states fell under the
nominal control of the mighty ottoman
empire which spanned from greece to
africa barbary privateers could be
called upon by the ottomans in times of
war and dragul's privateering had earned
him prestige among the ottoman
leadership most barbary rulers were in
fact corsairs themselves but today
dragoot possessed neither power nor
pride
he had been captured by italians after a
bloody raid and condemned to the oar a
backbreaking life aboard an italian
vessel in the sweltering belly of the
ship draggled heaved and pushed and
pulled to the oars day after day
his wiry muscles ached and his throat
grew parched and so the once notorious
pirate festered in obscurity
the man who had stolen and kidnapped
countless goods and people now appeared
destined to die
a slave
stripped of dragoot's prowess the
barbary pirates looked vulnerable
at this time charles v reigned over much
of europe and with the blessing of the
pope he called upon the nations of
christendom to sail out against the
ottoman-backed barbary pirates to
challenge the ottomans was a dangerous
proposition it was after all ottoman
overland hegemony that it initially
compelled europeans like columbus and
vasco de gama to seek alternative trade
routes to asia
nobody appreciated that fact more than
one aging conqueror who had joined the
fleet
hernan cortese peered out from a weather
beaten face wreathed by a beard that had
grown grey the man derided as a cruel
tyrant by many in central america had
returned to the seas of the old world to
challenge the barbary corsairs and
perhaps to reclaim some of the honor and
glory to which he felt so entitled
the fleet set out in 1541 to take back
the mediterranean under the command of
the genoese statesman andrea doria but
terrible storms beset the expedition and
tossed about the invading ships cortes
nearly drowned doria lost nearly 150
vessels when at last the remaining
soldiers made landfall the locals
massacred some and sold so many of the
survivors into slavery it was said the
price of a christian head became equal
to that of an onion
in the wake of this failed attack the
ottomans enjoyed unprecedented control
over the mediterranean under the cover
of drooping tents the markets of the
barbary coast every day bustled with the
fruitful exchange of goods and people
stolen from passing ships or the coasts
of west africa and europe
but even in the wake of victory the
barbary states felt the absence of
dragoot
he still sat behind rusty bars in genoa
the ottomans eventually surrounded the
city and threatened to lay siege to it
unless dragoot was set free the wary
genoese refused the ottomans paid a
fortune in ransom money although years
in slavery had drained dragoot freedom
proved invigorating he returned to the
seas with ferocity
in 1546 the ottoman sultan named him the
commander of the ottoman fleet and bay
of algier as the de facto leader of the
barbary corsairs dragoot rested control
of tripoli from the knights of saint
john and expelled european incursions on
the barbary coast and so in 1560 andrea
doria planned to destroy his rival again
his ships sailed out to swarm dragoot
but in the battle of gerba dragoot
decimated their fleet
and corsairs pulled the spanish from
their ships removed their heads and
stacked their skulls into a pyramid
dragoot had overseen the apex of ottoman
control in the mediterranean he died in
battle a few years later
the barbary states he left behind were
destined to change
english and dutch naval powers pushed
the barbary corsairs into a tenuous
peace in the 17th century the barbary
states were forced to move away from
large-scale attacks on shipping in the
mediterranean and shifted their focus
instead to slavery
and so now we return to the atlantic
the quiet seaside village of baltimore
sat where the rocky coast meets verdant
irish hills
squinting from the shore villagers
noticed strange sails one day in 1631
armed barbary pirates
disembarked
baltimore was left a ghost town little
more than shattered windows and the
scattered belongings of missing people
every man woman and child who hadn't
managed to flee was brought in chains
to the barbary coast a priest watched
their arrival in the slave market it was
a pitious sight to see them exposed for
sale at algiers for when they parted the
wife from the husband and the father
from the child then say aye they sell
the husband here and the wife there
tearing from her arms the daughter whom
she cannot hope to see ever again
enslaved men were likely to spend their
years as galley slaves whilst women and
children were liable to be forced into
concubinage and as europeans would soon
come to appreciate slave trading paid
handsomely
crossing the atlantic the spanish
enslaved indigenous people to extract
wealth from american soil this new land
and wealth soon attracted rival colonial
powers while the spanish claimed central
and most of south america and portugal
claimed brazil the english dutch and
french began to encroach and establish
colonies in north america if the old
world's age of mass privateering had
seen its heyday under dragoot the new
world's golden age of privateering had
just begun
lollanae would squeeze out the eyes burn
the flesh and remove the tongues of
those who refused to tell him what he
wanted to hear
now lolane demanded that the captured
spaniard tell him the truth whether or
not he knew a safe unguarded path to the
city of san pedro the spaniard
undoubtedly sensed that the frenchman
planned to raid the city and torture
from its civilians every ounce of wealth
that they possessed and so the man told
lolinae that he knew no such way to san
pedro the story continues
having asked them all and found they
could show him no other way lolane grew
outrageously passionate so that he drew
his cutlass and with it cut open the
breast of one of these poor spaniards
and pulling out his heart began to bite
and gnaw it with his teeth like a
ravenous wolf saying to the rest i will
serve you all alike if you show me not
another way hereupon those miserable
wretches promised to show him another
way
it was cold cruelty that had lifted
lolinae from the misery of indentured
servitude to the heights of pirate
leadership he had captured treasure
ships and pillaged towns all the while
attracting followers to his cause like
other so-called buccaneers he operated
out of the neglected island of tortuga
over the years his fleet of one
ramshackle ship had swelled to eight but
now the spanish looked prepared
when he reached san pedro they repelled
his attack
fortune continued to turn against him he
sailed along the central american coast
and his ship ran aground
to this effect he determined to go on to
the coast of cartagena but god almighty
the time of his divine justice being now
come had appointed the indians of darien
to be the instruments and executioners
thereof
hither loloney came brought by his evil
conscience that cried for punishment
thinking to act his cruelties but the
indians within a few days after his
arrival took him prisoner and tore him
in pieces alive
throwing his body limb by limb into the
fire and his ashes into the air that no
trace nor memory might remain of such an
infamous inhuman creature
contemporaries of lollanae judged him a
wicked man but his rise had been made
possible by the unique conditions
brought about by rivalries among
overstretched empires and nurtured in
the backwater regions to which spain
tenuously laid claim
lolinae was part of a new and growing
class of pirate
known in this age
as buccaneers
buccaneers had always existed in
defiance of the spanish crown but they
hadn't always been pirates they had
gotten their start as poor settlers who
ventured into the overgrown north end of
spanish hispaniola to rustle feral
cattle and pigs the forest dwellers sold
this meat to english dutch and french
merchants in exchange for weapons
ammunition and rum since hispaniola's
native taino people had traditionally
cooked meat on wooden frames called
bakken the french and english took to
calling these meat smugglers bocaniers
or buccaneers the spanish meanwhile
referred to these english dutch and
french merchants as interlopers to
safeguard their monopoly and ward them
off they drove the buccaneers from
hispaniola and decimated the animals
they hunted but in doing so the spanish
inadvertently created a pirate haven the
island of tortuga
a tropical paradise where from the 1630s
onward disaffected smugglers could
carouse with french english and dutch
interlopers and build a caribbean black
market
soon the men of tortuga turned to piracy
the buccaneers began to sail out on
small boats in the dead of night to
ambush spanish trade ships around this
time the french and dutch arose as
commercial and naval rivals to the
spanish in the 30 years war which pitted
the catholic habsburg rulers of spain
and austria against the dutch republic
and the rival bourbon house of france
spain's grasp on the new world was
loosening
the english established colonies across
the north american east coast and the
french began to venture from canada to
louisiana but despite this dizzying
succession of 17th century wars between
european powers the politics in
caribbean waters were refreshingly
simple
the spanish
or the enemy
regardless of goings on in europe
governors in the west indies had made
their choice colonial authorities
weaponized the buccaneers of tortuga
with letters of mark and let them loose
on the spanish
[Music]
the buccaneers smelt blood in the water
they raided cities along the spanish
main and spain's merchant ships africans
escaped slaves and outlaws also joined
their ranks
in spite of the sadism practiced by
buccaneers like lolinae these
self-titled brethren of the coast
generally boasted a commonwealth spirit
whereby decisions were made collectively
resources were pooled together and loot
was divided according to well-understood
parameters like the english sea dogs of
francis drake's time or the barbary
pirates buccaneers towed the line
between roguish outlaws and agents of
the state
when war finally reached tortuga it was
english colonial authorities who
graciously provided a new buccaneer
haven
england had taken jamaica in 1655 and
its city of port royal now provided
implicit support for these anti-spanish
privateers under the regal banner of
england the buccaneers arrived in ships
stocked with plundered rum slaves cloth
and cash crops the ensuing trade
facilitated the scandalous metamorphosis
of port royal into the so-called sodom
of the new world
here a buccaneer could squander his
spanish loot cheer and brawl in a muggy
tavern or unwind on the warped mattress
of a busy brothel when one clergyman
retired from his attempts to preach to
the inhabitants of port royal he
remarked the majority of its population
consists of pirates cutthroats [ __ ]
and some of the vilest persons in the
whole of the world
port royal became a black market boom
town that rivaled the upright prosperity
of england's puritan boston
tortuga meanwhile continued to serve as
a neutral port for buccaneers
and it was into this world of
opportunity that henry morgan sailed in
the early 1660s the sailor in his early
30s had cut his teeth as a welsh
privateer sacking spanish cities steady
deep-set brown eyes betrayed a cunning
self-assuredness he had trained under
powerful buccaneers
but the time had come to build his own
legacy
anchoring in port royal he flaunted his
english letter of mark it authorized
attacks on spanish shipping and unsavory
sailors wallowing in the town's taverns
were keen to take advantage 12 ships and
500 english and frenchmen sailed out
under morgan's command in a matter of
days morgan had become the de facto king
of the buccaneers
[Music]
the invasion fleet dropped ankar on the
haitian coast morgan rallied the
buccaneers and stormed the city of
puerto del principe they killed hundreds
of spanish defenders and pillaged for
three days but their earnings were
insufficient
the buccaneers moaned and cursed until
morgan offered up an idea they would
move on to the panamanian coast and
attack the city of portobello
stocked full of shimmering spanish
treasure but crawling with well-trained
militiamen portobello was a dangerous
prize
the french who had followed morgan thus
far bulked at the idea and sailed off
if our number is small our hearts are
great and the fewer persons we are the
more union and better shares we shall
have in the spoil
the unwavering morgan roused the
remaining crew and guided his fleet
quietly through the bokkers del toro
they transferred into smaller vessels
when they reached the coast the weary
pirates staggered onto the beach and
marched towards portobello at daybreak
they charged
the morning silence was split by musket
fire morgan and his men advanced in a
haze of black powder women screamed and
children fled the buccaneers fired at
every living thing in sight
morgan overran the city but the precious
citadel of fort santiago still loomed in
the distance the spanish militia atop
its walls rained down stones and
explosive parts on all who neared the
fort morgan thus pulled back and
adjusted his strategy he readied siege
ladders and corralled the city's nuns
and friars forcing them to march forth
in a human shield
thus the ladders were put into the hands
of religious persons of both sexes and
these were forced at the head of the
companies to raise and apply them to the
walls
thus many of the religious men and nuns
were killed before they could fix the
ladders which at last being done though
with great loss of the said religious
people the pirates mounted them in great
numbers being now on top of the walls
they kindled and cast in among the
spaniards
the buccaneers killed the governor in
front of his own wife and daughter and
wounded or killed every other spaniard
therein with portobello hostage henry
morgan seized an opportunity he sent a
letter to the governor of panama
tomorrow we plan to burn this city to
the ground and then set sail with all
the guns and munitions from the castles
with us we will take all our prisoners
and we will show them the same kindness
that the english prisoners have received
in this place
morgan added that he would spare the
city of this fate if the governor
promptly paid him three hundred and
fifty 000 pieces of eight
from their conquered forts morgan's
buccaneers repulsed the panamanian
counter-attack negotiated a ransom for a
hundred thousand pieces of eight and
sailed off
however news of changing diplomatic
tides met them on the docks and spoiled
their homecoming
it appeared the age of the buccaneer was
coming to a close
england had adopted friendlier relations
with spain and the crown now rebuked
this wave of piracy henry morgan was
forced to retire
but not for long
global communication in those days was
fraught with delay local spanish
authorities ignorant of the new truce
sent out privateers to exact revenge on
the english for the portobello raid
their hostility in turn provided morgan
with an opportunity to return to the
seas and fulfill an earlier promise to
sack the most prized metropolis in the
americas
panama city
and so in early 1671 morgan readied the
buccaneers for his greatest plan yet
they overran the city scavenged all the
wealth they could find brutalized the
inhabitants and burnt it to the ground
morgan was arrested for piracy and
transported to london in 1672 for
punishment but by the time he had
arrived the diplomatic winds had turned
yet again
spain had elected to support the dutch
in the third anglo-dutch war and was
therefore again an enemy of england
morgan walked free while throngs of
commoners and royalty alike hailed him
as a national hero who had ravaged the
hated spanish
but in the coming decades rarer and
stricter letters of marx saw less
cooperation between buccaneers of
different nations and eventually fewer
buccaneers altogether the reign of the
buccaneers ended not in glorious battle
but in stuffy courtrooms and royal
negotiations
by the time of his death in 1688 the
gentrified henry morgan had turned his
piratical earnings into several
profitable plantations raked and picked
by over a hundred miserable slaves it
was said that morgan gorged himself on
food and drink in his final years
privateers like himself had maintained
the diplomatic veneer of national
service they attacked and stole within
recognized parameters set by colonial
authorities
the next generation of pirates would
dispense with such niceties
unshackled by diplomacy and unburdened
by the weight of nation the men of the
black flag answered to no one they knelt
before no king
the caribbean was at their mercy
a dozen sails rippled above panicked
crews hundreds of cannons had been
employed to ensure the safety of this
12-ship floater the spanish were doing
what they had done for more than a
century heaving gold home from the new
world
but on this occasion the figure that
captured the horizon wasn't a black flag
but a dark tempest
dread overcame the sailors it was too
late to escape
black clouds flooded the skies and
furious seas took hold of the ships
desperate men clung to the masks which
tore asunder sails flew into the deluge
sailors tumbled into the void one
galleon was thrown against the reef its
hulking shadow sunk into the depths with
a drowned crew left to rot in the dark
of its cabin
eleven of the twelve vessels suffered
the same fate
in the morning warm sunlight penetrated
the clouds and shimmered on calm seas
the storm had claimed over a thousand
men scattered amongst their drifting
corpses were precious metals and fine
silks
seven million pieces of eight worth of
south american treasure
this veritable fortune in gold and
silver had been slated to sustain the
spanish empire for the next year it
needed to be salvaged the spanish at
havana immediately set out an expedition
to recover it but word of the wreck had
gotten out
[Music]
captain henry jennings sailed to the
gulf and found the spaniards there upon
the wreck the money before spoken of was
left on shore deposited in a storehouse
the rovers came directly onto the place
bringing their little fleet to an anchor
and landing 300 men they attacked the
guard who immediately ran away and thus
they seized the treasure which they
carried off making the best of their way
to jamaica
among the nerdu wells of port royal
charles vane had appeared to cut a
thoroughly unremarkable figure but he
had had ambition enough to join his more
diplomatic friend the former privateer
henry jennings who had managed to cobble
together a crew the gentlemanly jennings
had intended to stop the spanish salvage
expedition and steal as much treasure
from the wreckage as he could and
together that they did
on their way home from their successful
expedition jennings and vane encountered
a spanish ship they raided it too stole
the treasure aboard and went on their
way but selling their loot was
complicated the world had again turned
against the pirate
gone were the days of unrestrained
buccaneering against the spanish
this was peacetime and london saw to it
that its british colonies disavowed
jennings and the other pirates during
the war of spanish succession england
the dutch republic and portugal had
rallied against france over the rightful
heir to the childless spanish king
charles ii
bloodshed and conquest had returned to
the caribbean and the privateers roamed
free
but now the winds had turned yet again
and the debaucherous doors of port royal
were closed to stolen goods and maritime
outlaws
if men like henry jennings and charles
vane were going to become pirates they
needed friendly ports and a new base of
operations
only a few years removed from war the
bahamian island of new providence and
its city of nassau sat scarred and
nearly abandoned green and red-throated
parrots warbled above decaying forts
which hadn't flown british colours in
years
frothy waves lapped against white shores
and leaning palm trees nassau also
boasted a natural harbour that could
hold a hundred ships located near trade
routes and the wreckage of the treasure
fleet this was the scene the former
privateer benjamin hornigold stumbled
upon a new eden bereft of any semblance
of government
hornigold quickly assumed control and
gave the pirates exactly what they
needed jennings vane and thousands of
other disaffected sailors were welcomed
into the pirates paradise of nassau
the pirates clambered ashore with
pistols and swords and faces freckled
with scurvy spots here they spent their
ill-gotten wealth on rolls of dice
rounds of rum and seedy nights in
run-down brothels
chests of immaculate gold and silver
from the wreckage made their way into
town
in the throes of treasure fever the
pirates indulged in the lawler success
from the fortified pools of nassau
captains could launch attacks on passing
merchant vessels
in the commonwealth of pirates he who
goes to the greatest length of
wickedness is looked upon with a kind of
envy amongst them as a person of more
extraordinary gallantry and is thereby
entitled to be distinguished by some
post and if such a one has but courage
he must certainly be a great man
the pirates attacked merchant ships
hauling in tobacco rum cotton tar sugar
and slaves before returning to the
safety of nassau englishmen attacked
englishmen without regard for common
heritage bold brutality became a badge
of pride
but for all its anarchical trappings
nassau came to be governed in a sense by
two rival pirate factions
one under henry jennings and the other
under benjamin hornigold hornigold's
rising second in command edward teach or
blackbeard also held sway despite this
top-down tyranny had no place in nassau
in a period when monarchies were
widespread and common sailors languished
under draconian captains for poor wages
this so-called republic of pirates
embraced fraternity and
proto-egalitarianism in its undaunting
pursuit of wealth half a century before
the eloquent democratic treatises of
payne and jefferson the pirate ship
became a primordial site of defiance
toward absolutism and monarchy
indeed the pirates of this era made
decisions collectively voted out
incompetent and unfair captains and
shared their loot
many followed pirate codes that harshly
penalized disloyalty and the cheating of
one's own crew while many still reserved
harsh violence for their victims pirates
like blackbeard spurned violence deemed
unnecessary cultivating instead an aura
of fear to force victims into
surrendering without resistance
the pirate flag or jolly roger was
intended for just this purpose the red
or black flag often flew emblazoned with
icons of death skulls bones and
hourglasses
pirates used flags strategically tailing
target vessels and hoisting the feared
emblem of piracy when close enough to
make good on their implicit threat to
unleash carnage
[Music]
but by 1726 king george the first had
had enough from the opulence of his
palace he made a dramatic move to
annihilate the pirate threat
and conquer nassau
his plan was to fracture whatever unity
these pitiful enemies of the state
professed his majesty had issued a royal
pardon in this carrot and stick approach
pirates who surrendered to the proper
authorities in the coming year would be
pardoned and free to carry on with their
lives but those who rejected this
proposal would in turn receive a price
on their head and a royal promise that
they would be hunted down arrested and
killed
when news from new york of the impending
pardon reached the shores of nassau
hundreds of pirates rejoiced henry
jennings and benjamin hornigold and many
other former privateers had never
intended to be reviled pirates prophet
had possessed them but now they saw a
fortuitous escape to the world of
respectable commerce amidst their
euphoria the pro-pardoned pirates
restored the union jack atop the fort of
nassau
but there was a schism
hundreds of men refused to return to the
mundane poverty of civility those who
embraced the life of a ship-borne outlaw
and the bloody quest for fortune and
leisure these pirates including edward
england christopher billy onehand
condont and calico jack rackham now
found a leader in the most die-hard
anti-pardoned pirate of them all
charles
vane vane rallied his supporters and
staged an armed takeover of the fort he
tore down the union jack and raised high
the grinning face of death the black
flag for the time being nasser would
remain the unapologetic property of
pirates a brazen island of liberty chaos
and wealth
in their defiance of king george charles
vane and his supporters even attempt to
drop support from the jacobite cause
which sought to restore the deposed
house of stuart upon the british throne
although the bid was unsuccessful
tensions in nassau were rising a pirate
council was called in 1718.
vane argued that they should fortify the
island and stand against the british
his old friend henry jennings disagreed
he advocated taking the pardon a great
clamor and shouting came over the room
and nothing was decided upon the
republic of pirates felt irrevocably
fractured
and the end
appeared close
and indeed the exodus had begun henry
jennings and 15 of his men sailed to
british bermuda and formally received
pardons others fitted their ships for
long piratical journeys elsewhere to
south america or africa blackbeard
meanwhile had not been seen for months
in february the hms phoenix arrived in
nassau captain vincent pierce formally
offered the pirates the king's pardon
benjamin hornigold and the pro-pardoned
pirates happily accepted they warned
pierce of the zealous charles vane who
was at that very moment outfitting a
ship for piracy captain pierce sailed
around the island and let loose a volley
of cannon fire on vain's vessel
arresting charles vane in a show of good
faith to the pirates he released him
again and so vain and his crew accepted
the king's pardon with the promise that
they would turn away from piracy
pierce also informed them that the
former buccaneer woods rogers had been
appointed governor of nassau and would
arrive in the summer to take the island
and restore order
vane had accepted the pardon in the
moment but he hadn't the slightest
intention of keeping his word
[Music]
rebellion
grew
and so sailing past pierce charles vane
hoisted the black flag in defiant
theatricality and left nassau to exact
cruelties on nearby trade routes for
three weeks vayne continued on like this
hacking and hanging his victims he
captured a dozen merchant ships and
crippled trade in the bahamas when he
finally sailed back to nassau vane was
delighted to find that pierce had
departed but something else ominous soon
appeared
a hulking five-vessel fleet with
towering warships approached and laid
anchor
blackbeard was in town
his 700 strong crew found their land
legs in the taverns and brothels of
nassau and for a brief moment it looked
like the glorious pre-pardoned days of
the island had returned
blackbeard however was not keen on a
potential run-in with woods rogers and
in a few days he and his crew sailed
away
finally vane attacked benjamin hornegold
and proclaimed himself the governor of
new providence it seemed charles vane
was the last true pirate lord in this
corner of the world old allies had
turned against him henry jennings had
even accepted a privateering commission
to arrest vane but vain rich with the
spoils of his exploits now planned to
set sail for brazil with his crew where
they might regroup and build another
pirate paradise
but as they readied their ships hostile
sails appeared
woods rogers blocked vane in the harbour
this was the final chance to take the
pardon and escape
alive
all surrendered to the pardon except
charles vane and his crew which happened
after this manner the harbour had two
inlets by means of a small island lying
at the mouth of it at one of which both
the men of war entered and left the
other open so that vanes slipped his
cable set fire to a large prize they had
there and resolutely put out firing at
the man of war as he went off
despite this attack woods rogers
nevertheless became the governor of new
providence and he entrusted benjamin
hornergold with a dangerous mission to
hunt down charles vane but vane had
informants and old allies scattered
across the west indies and he shrunkly
evaded rogers and horner gold at every
turn
as charles vane persisted in a bloody
tour of piracy dozens of superficially
reformed pirates betrayed the pardon
stole ships and sailed off to join his
course
if arrested they would be tried under
maritime law and thus afforded no jury
pirate trials were little more than a
show well-promoted propaganda intended
to sear a gruesome image in the minds of
all would-be pirates without the aid of
a defense lawyer the mostly illiterate
sea thieves would be asked to prove
their innocence to a panel of appointed
officials the accused would inevitably
be found guilty hanged on the foreshore
and buried in an unmarked grave or left
to rot in a swinging cage this was the
fate the crown had now reserved for all
pirates
but charles vane pressed onwards
[Music]
while many of his old crew like edward
england and christopher condont had left
for africa and brazil one powerful
pirate still stalked american waters
vane found blackbeard in the ocracoke
inlet off the coast of north carolina
and ordered cannons fired in a salute to
his fellow pirate
as the two crews fraternized and drank
for several nights on the beach vane
likely attempted to convince blackbeard
to sail with him but blackbeard again
sailed off separately intent on staging
a few last attacks on vulnerable targets
before his own planned retirement from
piracy
only a month later in november of 1718
british lieutenant robert maynard caught
up to blackbeard and launched a surprise
attack blackbeard quickly fired back his
crew wounded or killed 21 of the british
attackers and boarded the enemy vessel
to finish the job but a dozen british
sailors lay hidden in the hold they
emerged and charged with maynard across
a deck sleek with blood in a haze of
musket fire the giant blackbeard
appeared and lunged at the rival captain
maynard locked swords with blackbeard
swinging furiously the pair dueled until
at last maynard struck his challenger
the enormous pirate shattered the sword
lodged inside of him and reached for his
pistol but again maynard was quicker and
shot him
here was an end of that courageous brute
who might have passed in the world for a
hero had he been employed in good cause
the lieutenant caused blackbeard's head
to be severed from his body and hung up
at the bold spirit end then he sailed to
bathtown to get relief for his wounded
men
it might have seemed prudent for charles
vane to avoid a similar fate and he
retreated when a french naval ship fired
on him just a day later but his crew
took his caution for cowardice in
accordance with the pirate code the crew
exercised their right to vote him out
his shipmate calico jack rackham took
the helm and with a small gang of loyal
supporters charles vane was sent off in
a mega sloop he continued to attack and
rob merchant vessels but soon a dark
storm descended upon his ship the small
vessel screeched and teetered over
thunderous swells vane and the crew were
thrashed about the deck until the waves
overtook them their plunder was lost and
the crew was thrown
overboard
and yet
this wasn't
the end
among the drifting wreckage that washed
up on the still shores of a desert
island was splintered wood strips of
sail and the captain himself charles
vane
the castaway had cheated death he
crawled ashore through clumped sand and
cursed his wretched lot here on some
unknown stretch of land vane languished
days passed under a beating sun he spent
his hours gazing out at a desolate
blue-green horizon seeing not another
soul at last a group of turtle hunters
stopped by to find a stinking and hungry
child's vein dressed in weather-worn
clothes they provided the miserable
pirate with turtle flesh to sustain
himself and continued on their way
vane remained brooding on the island for
weeks until in early 1719 he spotted his
saving opportunity an english vessel
from jamaica stopped on the island vane
happened to be an old acquaintance of
its commander captain halford but
holford was a retired buccaneer who knew
vane well enough to bar the conniving
pirate from boarding still some part of
hulford took pity on the castaway rather
than a rest vane outright hulford gave
his old friend a running start
i am now going down the bay and shall
return hither in about a month if i find
you upon the island when i come back
i'll carry you to jamaica and hang you
holford sailed off and vane was left to
scour the horizon for a rescuer within a
few days another english ship arrived
the sailors met the weary castaway and
heard his sympathetic plight vane gave
them a false name and joined their crew
they began to sail out of the bay
one would be apt to think that vane was
now pretty safe and likely to escape the
fate which his crimes had merited but
here a cross accident happened that
ruined all holford returning from the
bay was met by this ship the captains
being very well acquainted together
holford was invited to dine and as he
passed along to the cabin he chanced to
cast his eye down the hold and there saw
charles vane at work
holford arrested vane at gunpoint and
carried the chained pirate back to
jamaica there authorities finally locked
him in a cell
the anti-piracy efforts of the crown had
worked well in short order the last of
the great pirates would disappear
including those who had fled eastward
pardoned men like henry jennings could
retire in domesticity the thousands who
refused the king's offer were hunted
down and hanged
others lost their lives on the high seas
some would be dashed against rocks in
hurricanes the great bartholomew roberts
was shot in the throat and still others
like the brutal edward lowe who
notoriously forced a man to eat his own
broiled lips
disappeared
though likely captured and killed a
wishful caribbean criminal might imagine
missing pirates like lowe and henry
every had made it out alive
that they had cheated the hangman and
lived out the rest of their days sipping
rum amidst their plunder
as for charles vane a year in prison
culminated in a stuffy trial flanked by
crimson-clad colonial guardsmen and on
march 29 in the year 1721 vane was
walked to gallows point in the once
lawless port royal and hanged by the
neck
until he died
his executioners placed his lifeless
body in a cage which teetered for years
at the harbour's entrance of gun k such
that the rotting flesh of charles vane
nourished the passing crow and his
slumping visage prophesied the fate of
all who sailed under the black flag
[Music]
let me ask you my dear marquis in such
an enlightened in such a liberal age how
is it possible the great maritime powers
of europe should submit to pay an annual
tribute to the little piratical states
of barbary wood to heaven we had a navy
able to reform those enemies to mankind
or crush them into non-existence
the barbary states which had so
terrified europe under the likes of
dragoot had over the centuries modified
the primary means by which they
extracted wealth from the seas
they now guaranteed safe passage for the
feeble merchant ships that crossed the
mediterranean so long as their mother
countries submitted to pay an exorbitant
tribute
to the barbary corsair leaders if not
the barbary corsairs would do what they
had always done capture the boats and
kill ransom or enslave
everyone aboard
the course even forced the fledgling
united states of america to pay the
tribute for passage into the
mediterranean by 1797 the americans had
paid in total a fifth of their annual
budget to the barbary states despite the
protests of taxpayers the united states
had little choice but to pay they lacked
the naval might to counter the growing
barbary demands their eventual refusal
to pay prompted the corsairs to capture
american vessels and sell the men aboard
in their slave markets the monetary loss
buttressed by the image of enslaved
white americans proved galvanizing
president thomas jefferson raised an
expensive fleet that sailed out to
bombard the barbary states
[Music]
in the coming years warships would burn
and whole crews would perish in the
fighting sweden and sicily also took up
arms against their barbary enemies until
at last the barbary states relented 1815
saw a three-day second barbary war and a
renewed european commitment to suppress
the corsairs after the napoleonic wars
this was the downfall of these once
powerful pirates who had roamed the seas
since the middle ages
by that time the war of 1812 had ended
and many privateers employed by the
british and americans found themselves
without work a simultaneous wave of
revolutions severed spain's hold on her
new world colonies the coasts of latin
america and the caribbean thus became
once again
fertile ground for pirates
but the combined efforts of
industrializing world powers undermined
their strength president james monroe
spearheaded the efforts to eradicate
piracy meanwhile state-sanctioned forms
of armed robbery also disappeared from
the high seas as nations moved away from
the practice of privateering these
trends were codified in
anti-privateering proclamations and
multinational movements such that the
seas once harassed by the sea peoples
the visual brothers and the buccaneers
now waxed and waned a little more
quietly and trade ships followed their
roots with a little more monotony a man
called charles gibbs graced these
closing pages of pirate history without
an ounce of shame when arrested and
convicted in 1831 the american pirate
admitted the murder of 400 people and
readily told of buried treasure the
quantity of money buried in different
parts of the west india islands is
beyond calculation immense treasures
have been secreted there a great portion
of which will never be found
gibbs was brought to the very same speck
of land that would usher in a new global
urbanized age
under the gaze of lady liberty ellis
island would soon receive millions of
hopeful immigrants into the united
states and it was there that charles
gibbs
was hanged
piracy had always been complicated
theft torture murder and enslavement
were perpetrated on the high seas by
peoples states and individuals
possessing varying degrees of legal
support men like francis drake or henry
morgan might have recoiled at the
assertion that they were anything but
law-abiding patriots they fancied
themselves heroes to be lorded and not
outlaws to be feared
charles gibbs however
was different
from the alleged buried treasure to the
absurd number of deaths for which he
took credit it is thought that much of
his post-conviction confession was
fabricated that perhaps the ill-fated
gibbs desired in his final days to hoist
his legend alongside the pantheon of
pirates who once roamed these waters
outlaws like blackbeard henry avery and
charles vane
men for whom piracy was not merely
maritime banditry born out of
desperation but a proud culture a
defiant flag raised brutally against
imperial excess
an unjust enterprise unburdened by the
pretense of altruism where shameless
greed and sadism
might lie alongside nascent
republicanism in garish harmony
it was at the tail end of the golden age
in july of 1723
when a periodical known as the monthly
mercury recounted a bit of news from the
west indies
this day 26 of the pirates taken by his
majesty's ship the greyhound captain
solgaard were executed here their black
flag under which they had committed
abundance of piracies and murders was
affixed to one corner of the gallows
it had in it the portraiture of death
with an hourglass in one hand and a dart
in the other striking into a heart and
three drops of blood delineated as
falling from it
this flag they called old roger and used
to say
they would live
and die
under it
[Music]
you